hey what's going on with brexit well the
sure has been a lot of political
squabbling here at ground level let's
float away from all that for a look at
the big picture up here it's easier to
see the one-two-three of the impossible
Trinity but first quick British Isles
primer the United Kingdom contains
England Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland this last part of the United
Kingdom shares the island of Ireland
with the country of Ireland this Ireland
is in the European Union and the United
Kingdom is well that's the whole thing
isn't it
before UK voted to brexit the European
Union wall encircled them all the wall
isn't literal it's a metaphor for the
overlapping circles of even institutions
and border complications impossible to
draw so it's a metaphor wall maximum
brexit is the exit where UK leaves to
build her own wall separate from the EU
and be like any other country this
maximum brexit is the top of the trinity
with a wall around the UK which
following the border would go straight
across the irish island oh oh no the
books on Ireland Northern Ireland's and
the UK is long and complicated and
sometimes frightening relationship are
not tomes to be opened here the much
shorter and safer version is there used
to be a wall between the Ireland's but
there was a lot of the violence and a
lot of the troubles until on a very good
Friday Ireland in the UK agreed there
would never be a wall between them again
full stop this while it didn't
uncomplicated ship at least made it
nonviolent a new wall plowing between
them would break this vital political
promise
thus UK and Ireland and even you all
agree a wall here is super no bueno
no wall across Ireland is the second
vertex of the impossible Trinity wait
why do we need a wall anyway oh right
the maximum brexit creates a land border
with the EU because UK is an island unto
herself mostly but not completely so if
UK says this is unacceptable and all
agree this is unacceptable then the wall
could go here maybe aa compromise UK
tries to march out of the EU but not
everybody makes it Northern Ireland
stays in the EU sort of on the other
side of the wall while still being part
of the UK while the EU whispers into her
ear that were she to let go and unite
with Ireland that's cool with EU ain't
no thing girl poor Northern Ireland
she's on Ireland but mostly thinks of
herself as British but also Irish but
could end up being the last part of the
UK in the U while also having the right
to leave the UK and join Ireland if she
ever votes - for UK this situation means
a wall inside the United
no nation wants to create an external
wall through internal territory thus the
final vertex of the Trinity no walls
inside the UK leaving Northern Ireland
behind while staying connected to her
also means some of those overlapping few
institutions can pass through the wall
making Britain's brexit rather less than
maximum and political geography being
what it is that's it for options this
this or this
all of which the UK refuses but you
wanted the wall in a different place
that was like your whole thing
none of these are acceptable thus the
impossible Cheney where the UK must pick
a side
promising no walls means no maximum
brexit promising maximum brexit means
there's got to be a wall somewhere and
so for a long time nothing of
consequence happened can you pick now
what if I put the wall here but only
temporarily that doesn't solve anything
that just kicks the Northern Ireland
down the road until we're right back
where we started so that's what's been
going on with brexit there's nothing as
permanent as a temporary solution and
ultimately there's no avoiding the
Trinity there's three things
pick two
you can go now
[Music]